Jack yes what's up it's time for things
you thought you knew or if we actually
said it from my
perspective stuff you about to
learn stuff you never knew is that what
cuz you know damn well you didn't know
it
[Music]
before I have to address something that
I think we've seen in the news you know
every six months goes by and then you
see a headline oh uh astrophysicists
have to rethink the Big Bang or big
bang debunked or or did you did you see
any of these at any time oh my god there
but well recently the James web Space
Telescope supposedly the headline is um
did the James we webs telescope um make
scientists think the the big bang or has
the James web telescope debunked the Big
Bang yeah it makes excellent clickbait
yeah there it is it's it's clickbait
headline so let me just explain a few
things that's going on here okay uh on
the frontier of scientific
research it is a bloody place all right
ideas are slave two scientists enter one
scientist
leaves it's the
Octagon welcome to science
doome
on the frontier ideas are contested
daily right and most ideas turn out to
be wrong all right so so what you are as
a scientist working on the frontier you
you're in this idea Factory that's what
you are and the successful idea is not
the one that's argued most strenuously
or argued by the most articulate yeah
that's called politics that's called
politics exactly exactly uh it's not it
has nothing to do with either of those
it has to do with
evidence all right which idea is
supported by evidence so typically what
happens is you can test your ideas and
here's where you have to be convincing
you have to say I I think my idea is
better than your idea and here's a way
to test it right so I I have an idea so
if you don't like me the way you show it
is you design an experiment to show I'm
wrong okay that's some Cutthroat nasty
that's some it's oh it's it's some nasty
all right that's some real housewi stuff
real
housewives let me tell you something
fedra your
hypothesis is
trash
trash so so scientists contest their
ideas so you uh you don't like me and
you going show me that I'm wrong and so
you go home and you invent an experiment
expent you invent an experiment to test
my idea with the objective of showing
that I'm wrong and it turns out hey wait
a minute I'm getting what the dude says
right you got to publish that and then
someone else performs
a performs another kind of experiment
aimed at testing the same
hypothesis and they got kind of the same
result and then someone from a different
country with a different wall current
240 volts maybe and they plug their
stuff in and they're getting the same
results
when you have repeated experiments
verifying an idea we have a new
objective truth that has emerged in
those
sciences and what I'm telling you is
that the Big Bang Theory by the way if
you type that into Google you get the TV
show just I'm my personal jury is still
out on whether that's a good or bad
thing um you know it doesn't mean like
science is so popular it's a TV show and
that's the first thing you're hit
because you got to get through that then
there's the Big Bang is a K-Pop group
you got to get through that then you get
to the origin of the universe okay in
the Google search just thought I'd point
that out it's good to know that we
Google in order of
importance there it is just saying wow
all right so so here's the point the
tenants of the Big Bang
that the Universe started out small hot
dense uh where matter and energy were a
primordial soup where the forces of
nature had
merged all of that is Thoroughly
supported by observations of this
universe thoroughly
supported okay now there are some things
that well did this really cause that or
might it be something that we don't know
about yet
and who ordered up the dark matter we
don't know where that came from and
where's this expansion we don't know
where that came from but we can describe
it and we can measure it here's the
point if tomorrow you have a new idea
about how the universe
works it's going to enclose everything
we've been talking about up to that
moment that has been experimentally and
observationally
verified you can en close it something
deeper okay you can say what I have an
idea our universe is just one in a
Multiverse fine okay but our universe
would have started with a big bang okay
and our universe would have expanded
from a dense hot cool State and it's
been cooling ever since that's observed
and that's real and that's not going
away that's my point so so what you have
are journalists trying to make clickbait
and if there's some little thing in the
early universe that is still on the
frontier still being contested in the
Octagon in this in the in the fight Dome
and and and some new idea is emerging
over another idea say oh Big Bang is in
trouble scientists go back to the
drawing but big bang is not in trouble
right I'm just saying it's not in
trouble it is a whole
thing that could conceivably fit in a
deeper bigger idea right but it's not
going to be swapped out tomorrow we're
not going to find out tomorrow gee uh
the the early Universe was cold instead
of hot that's not going to happen that's
not how science works so if you're going
to come up with something
new you're not coming up
with something that will change the old
all you have to the old that has been
experimentally verified right if you're
going to come up with some something new
about the Earth and the Sun it's not
going to be well it's really Earth is
stationary and the Sun moves around the
Earth and the Sun is cold and Earth is
hot and Earth is what's Illuminating the
the Moon that is not going to happen
right right okay you can't just pull an
idea out of your orifice and ignore
experimental verification of what's
going on right so you might you might
come up with the Big Fang but you're not
changing the Big
Bang what's the big get a c plus on that
one yeah it's what it's what came before
the Big Bang we call it the big thing
the big thing
okay that's a B+ if
that's what's your thing yeah that's
before the Big Bang it's before the Big
Bang so and and by the way the when we
think of
einsteinian physics so it's relativity
which
completely uh usurped Newtonian gravity
and neonian motion all right what we
call CL the era of classical physics
which led right up to the late 18 00s
Newton's ideas reign supreme all right
and he told you what gravity did what
motion did an acceleration in a
pre-existing space and it was working
okay it was working and then people say
well wait a minute uh the orbit of
mercury is not really following Newton's
laws and we said oh we got this we we
know we got this there's a there's
another planet you can't see that's
tugging on it we even had a name for
that planet it was called Vulcan okay we
a hypothetical Planet tugging on Mercury
so that we didn't have to throw out
Newton's Laws all right so that was
invoked just out of we just pull that
out of our ass right said There It Is
we'll find it one
day Einstein comes along with a special
theory of relativity and then his
general theory of relativity and what we
find is that at high gravity like near
the Sun and at high speeds at High
gravity and high speeds Newton's Laws
completely fail you cannot use them at
all so do we say did we throw away
Newton no we didn't you know why because
if you take Einstein's equations and
plug in low speeds and low gravity they
become Newton's
equations yes so Einstein basically
enclosed Newton's
ideas as a special low speed low gravity
case of a much larger deeper
understanding of the universe that
fantastic it's it is it is it is
beautiful it is and so so and by the way
Newton's uh Newton's uh gravity and
Newton's motion were just fine for the
Apollo project right we got to the Moon
in back without any Einstein relativity
at all okay so it's only if you really
uh um up the stakes in and your gravity
there's no way to understand black holes
really with or even the Big Bang itself
with just Newtonian physics point is new
physics does not undo experimentally
verified physics that's the whole point
of experimental verification that's all
look at that and so the Big Bang is just
fine you want to do something else with
it take it body and soul and stick it in
some other Theory you have but you can't
undo what the experiments and
observations have shown and
that is an explainer for you there you
go wow that is good take that big big
bang deniers take that all right Chuck
we got to take a break but when we come
back more things you thought you knew on
Star
Talk there's a feature of the James web
Space Telescope that I haven't seen
talked about much people only just think
of it as some next big telescope that's
out there in space bringing us badass
images but there certain engineering
scientific
features that are unique with it that I
think are worth calling out okay that
sounds good if you can hang with me on
this all right uh allow me to remind us
that unlike Hubble which orbited Earth
360 mil up this thing is
parked A Million Miles Away in the
opposite direction of the Sun from the
earth it's pretty wild okay yeah and so
I say parked we're all or it and the
Earth are orbiting the Sun together and
so it so basically if you look back in
the earth Direction the sun will always
be there so it's it's using the Earth as
sun
block well it's it it has some motion
where it is okay but it's not going to
drift away from that location even
though there's some movement within the
location the the point is occasionally
Earth will block the Sun but the value
of this is you always know which way the
sun is right at all times okay it's
behind you okay right all right I'm
looking out to space the only way to
take good
pictures and know what they say like
good one yeah true get the sun behind
you that's right that's right so that
everyone is squinting as they look in
exactly
right
[Laughter]
so if you're G to take a picture of
something that's dim you either have to
illuminate it yourself which we really
can't do for the early universe that
doesn't work or you can take a long
exposure to allow the light to
accumulate but while you're taking that
long exposure you can't jiggle the
camera it has to be perfectly stationary
so Chuck just to repeat we can't take a
flash picture of the outer universe so
we have to open the exposure for a long
time okay so now watch uh different
bands of the electromagnetic spectrum
tell us different things about the
universe right so if you're going to do
that you need telescopes that specialize
in the chosen band and by the way we
didn't even know light came in bands
other than visible light somebody had to
discover that I mean just think about it
why would you have any inkling why would
you believe at all that there was a kind
of light out there that your eyes could
not detect right especially if you're
religious right if you're religious what
God made humans and we have eyeballs to
see light and how could there possibly
be something we can't see all right so
there's certain expectations of who and
what we are as a life form that were
completely
overrun the day infrared light was
discovered m
okay and did I tell you how they we
discovered infrared I tell you uhhuh but
it was did did we William hersel
discovered okay never mind tell the
story okay no real quick I was thinking
of something else I'm like okay wait a
minute William hersel discovered it and
uh how'd he do it he he knew that Isaac
Newton figured out that white light is
composed of colors you just pass it
through a prism and it breaks it apart
so he repeated this experiment you put a
little slit of light in your room but
the whole room has to be dark so that
only the Spectrum shows up all right and
you pass it through a triangle prism you
get a rainbow on your table and there it
is red orange yellow green blue violet
and he had the foresight to ask the
question I wonder if the different
colors of light have different
temperatures yeah just just to even ask
that question pretty uh pretty
impressive question think about that a
simple question may be retrospectively
obvious but at the time what okay so
what does he do he has a thermometer and
puts it in each of the different colors
of light but wait a minute you need a
control thermometer so he took his
control thermometer put it off to the
side just to the just to the side of the
red okay so that was not in the Spectrum
all right and he that would presumably
just measure room temperature all right
but it was still on the table where he
was measuring the rest of the
temperatures your control has to have a
minimum of variation other than the one
thing you want to change okay so the
thermometer is on the table but just off
to the side and so there he is he's
measuring the temperature of blue and
red and yellow and and what he's finding
is that the thermometer off to the side
is consistently measuring higher
temperature than all the rest of the
thermometers all the rest of the
readings that he was taking and he said
WTF I'm sure that's what he said okay
yes exactly I am sure and right after
that he went
OMG OMG
w2f all right so he publishes this
paper and it's just it's beautiful in
how he's tiptoeing around a discovery
because he doesn't really know he said
he could there be
light that is unfit for
vision unfit for vision this is how he
described it that's a great description
and he he does this enough and he I
think I've discovered light unfit for
vision you're damn right you did and was
it's light below the red and what do we
call it
infrared wow okay and it's so funny you
still see the huus of human um uh
existence there it's unfit for vision
not we can see
it we blind to this thing exactly it's
got the problem it's got the problem not
us it's unfit for us it's unfit for
vision i' thought about it that way very
good so so it turns out so that's just
an interesting sort of Discovery
experiment and then we would learn well
if that exists maybe other bands of
light exist and so thus thereafter we
would discover ultraviolet um um uh
microwaves radio waves X-rays and each
have their moment in the Sun so to speak
and that fills out the entire what we
call electromagnetic spectrum only a
small fraction is visible light and so
so now you're going to say what in the
universe gives off infrared light and
you find out that things that have kind
of any temperature at all will radiate
in the
infrared okay now so for example if you
have an electric stove and you put it on
low and turn out all the lights can you
see it no not if it's on low but you put
your hand on it you'll burn your hand
okay so something's about it something
is coming out of the stove and it's not
V unfit for vision right it's infrared
light okay and when the thing gets hot
enough it's not only giving off infrared
it'll begin to also give off visible
light right okay but if the thing is
cool enough it's primarily only going to
be giv you infrared suppose you want to
see infrared all right and by the way
infrared doesn't make it very nicely
through Earth's atmosphere you know how
you know this because we have greenhouse
gases that trap the infrared that is
down here okay so so the greenhouse
effect are molecules that have a special
relationship with infrared and there's
the ground trying to radiate infrared
back into space and said no you don't
and it sends it back down and
accumulates Okay so so here's the cool
thing about the James web telescope it
has a special reflective surface on its
mirrors that are tuned to reflect
infrared with very high efficiency
that's number one reflect in Focus
number two if you're trying to detect
something that is a very low
temperature what happens if you have a
temperature and you're the detector you
end up detecting yourself exactly can't
have that I went searching for the
universe and all I found was
me
so so so you need a way to cool the
telescope so we could send up cryogenic
liquids and things but they would
eventually evaporate or or gain
temperature and that so what we figured
out to do we not not I the engineers who
were tasked with this um that telescope
has a series of thermal
baffles between it and the
sun all right and so those just take a
look at any photo of the full telescope
deployed these these the they're
basically screen they're like sheets
that are that are put up a series of
them in the row so sunlight comes and
hits one of them it reflects some back
others get absorbed and gets
retransmitted to the next sheet but that
gets
resent back there's this multiple triple
Reflections and at each layer the amount
of heat from the Sun is dramatically
dropped okay dramatically by the time it
comes out the other side it's barely
there at all and so the temperature of
the telescope can now drop to what is
basically the temperature of deep space
without any influence of
sunlight uh uh increasing its its body
temperature if you will that's wild it's
totally wild so now the James web Space
Telescope can observe deep in the
infrared part of the spectrum because it
can and so there you have it that a
little primer on infrared and infrared
telescopes and how that works well there
you go people I hope you were paying
attention because you're going to be at
a cocktail party where this is going to
come in very very handy I plan on using
it this weekend I'm telling you right
now
it's what's that skirt for on the outer
edge of the telescope you know go I
suppose we didn't realize that there
were baffles that actually filter the
sunlight in such a way that cools the
telescope so that we're able to register
the infrared without registering the
heat from the telescope itself yes this
is the kind of stuff you learn when
you're an extremely smart individual by
the way off with you
okay that's why you don't many friends
left at your
party hi Chuck we got to take a quick
break but when we come back more things
you thought you knew on Star
talk so you might have heard
intermittently every now and
then that uh Earth's poles will flip
have you ever heard you've heard that
right I've heard people say it say it
well thank you for clarifying that right
right and clarifying that it's not what
is true it's what people say or think is
true these are not always the same thing
so the it was especially bandied about
when we were approaching not only the
year 2000 but also the year 2012 about
every 10 years people banned together
and wanted declare that the world is
about to end based on some Cosmic Force
right I'm intrigued I think that people
need need followers if you're the one
saying the world's going to end and no
one else is people will think you have
special knowledge and then you become
sort of this Guru of of
prognostication so let me just make it
clear that Earth's rotation axis with
Santa Claus at the top is not flipping
that is a completely stable
configuration we bob up and down a
little bit okay and so on our spinning
axis we not only press which is a fancy
word for wobble okay we wobble if you
ever played with a top as the top slows
down you see it wobble uh but also we
bob up and down okay and they all happen
on very different time scales but none
of them involve a flipping of Earth's
axis North and
South
however what does flip are the magnetic
poles the magnetic
poles now let me just nip something in
the bud here okay just so you know uh
you're old enough to have probably used
a compass in your life when you were a
kid all right okay uh which way does the
compass always Point North is the what
they say okay so that that's that's
correct and it it points to the north
magnetic pole all right right which by
the way does not exactly align with
Santa Claus all right okay there's by
the way there are things in the universe
where that it's almost at 90 degrees to
each other so there's there's nothing
specially it's it's no Cosmic
prerequirement that they perfectly align
in the spinning object all right so in
our case they don't align the North Pole
is sitting somewhere in Northern Canada
all right so if you trying to find Santa
Claus with a compass and you're in
Northern Canada you're going to land in
the wrong spot oh wow okay just to be
clear about that no wonder we can't find
them that's why you didn't get your
presents you didn't get your presents
this year's so good yeah you didn't get
your Pony yeah exactly I can't find this
you going pay what you ow
Santa so so it'll find the north
magnetic pole all right so that thing
that's pointing there is the North Pole
of the compass needle the compass needle
is itself a magnet with a north and a
South Pole now here's here's a little
known fact okay uh what can you tell me
about North and South poles of a
magnet that take two magnets together
what do they do well you know they repel
each other if it's the same po which
repels what which repel so north north
to North and South to South they each
repel each other right like charges
repel right so wait a minute if the
needle of a
compass that says North on it points to
the North
Pole shouldn't it
[Music]
be pointing in the opposite direction
right it should be repelled and pointing
down okay except it's not it's attracted
which tells you that Earth's South
magnetic pole is in the
north because the north part of all
magnets point in that direction okay
okay just I don't know if you knew that
no and you know like I here's the thing
you already you what you did was you
took the empirical and put it first and
then you said the ridiculous thing
afterwards so now what am I left to do
I'm like well he already proved it so
what am I goingon to do like yeah it's
it's pre it's
pre-approved sence like I can't be I
can't say like yeah right whatever you
know no no cuz you already were with me
on it exactly yes absolutely right you
so demonstrate this they don't tell you
that in the Boy Scouts no they don't
that you that the Earth's South magnetic
pole is in the north which is why all
North poles of magnets point there sorry
Little Tommy but you're screwed
uh your compass
is comp concept of reality is off by 180
degrees all right so here's what happens
uh we have a magnetic field because our
core is fluid all right all the heavy
stuff when Earth was molten uh the heavy
stuff fell to the middle and the heavy
stuff is the iron and the light stuff
which is the Rocks floated to the top
okay and we don't think of rocks is
light but it's much lighter than metal
all right and so all the metals nearly
all the metals went to the core some got
frozen in place and so you have these
ores these veins of ores as Earth is
solidifying it didn't fall down fast
enough and it got frozen in place there
are other occasions where volcanoes can
redistribute material from below and put
it up in the crust but basically most of
Earth's iron is in our core and it's hot
and so the iron is molten and you have
molten and you're spinning you have
moving
magnetically uh
chargeable Metals okay iron is ma is
magnetizable when you have moving metal
you create what's called a Dynamo and in
a Dynamo you basically create a magnetic
field from scratch wow that's why old
dead planets that have cooled do not
have magnetic fields right okay they
don't they don't have magnetic fields
like Mars no magnetic field to speak of
okay because it's it's cooled faster
than Earth did it's smaller so cool if
you're smaller you will cool faster and
so no there's not you don't have these
this
churning uh by the way Mars once did for
sure Mars has the largest known volcano
in the solar system okay so Mars used to
be hot in the inside but that's called
Olympus Mons all right right makes our
volcanoes look like mole Hills by the
way it's huge it's huge so anyhow the
point I'm getting that here is the
Dynamo goes through Cycles okay and it
goes It goes It goes stronger than it
goes weaker and it
flips got and so every half million
years or
so the magnetic field of Earth has
flipped period okay that's pretty wild
okay yeah it's it's it's it's
fascinating and while it's flipping it
actually goes to zero and then recovers
coming out the other
side okay so then that makes me ask what
does the magnetic field of Earth do for
Earth and do for us other than give
compasses a meaning in life yeah other
than confused um Boy Scouts who don't
understand that that the compass should
be pointing in the opposite direction
well Einstein was quite intrigued by a
compass that some mysterious force that
you can't see touch smell or taste is
forcing the needle to move he was very
intrigued by that as a child so I think
we' be thankful that we had compasses
back if it was just GPS with a handheld
device of finding North I think maybe
Einstein would not you know he might
have gone on to play basketball or
something who knows who knows what
career he might have
had so actually that's the opposite of a
Gary Larson comic that's where I I got
that idea from there's a a picture of
Einstein on a basketball court and he's
like dribbling right and it said uh
Albert Einstein uh in school was
destined to be to be uh you know
All-Star basketball player until an
ankle injury send him into his physics
books that's
funny so so the point is that so the
magnetic field has flipped and what the
magnetic field does when it's operating
is it creates a magnetic shield around
Earth if you will and when charged
particles come from the Sun the solar
wind we call it they see this magnetic
field and they spiral down towards the
poles ah or towards the magnetic poles
and as they spiral down they Corine into
air molecules and if you have two
molecules that collide with each other
energy gets exchanged okay so your your
energy of motion gets boosted into the
energy inside the molecule itself so
you've excited the molecule then on its
own timetable like fractions of a second
it de excites and then radiates visible
light so wait a minute what is that oh I
know what that is that's the Aurora
that's pretty wild the Aurora boralis
that's in the north and take a take a
gander what it's called in the South um
the oh let me see um the Southern Aurora
Borealis okay thank you Chuck
you know I'm okay with that no it's the
Aurora Australis the Aurora Australis
Australis right because it's symmetric
right we have a North Pole and a South
Pole so we make a big deal of our own
Aurora because 90% of the human
population of the world lives north of
the equator right so we get Aurora there
so there it is and and we know the field
is flipped you know why because you can
see volcanic planes where iron came out
and the iron aligned with the magnetic
field when it froze in
place and you compare this from
different generations of volcanic
eruptions and you can see the flipping
of the orientation of the of the iron
particles that is it's it it's
remarkable that is really outstanding
that's pretty wild because yeah the the
the the the mag it's a magnet so it's
metal in a magnet and it's actually um
um uh succumbing to the properties of
Mag of magnetism correct correct and if
Earth is helping that out it's going to
align them when it freezes out of the
volcanic uh flow so yeah no it's it's
pretty cool stuff and it all comes
together and by the this involved like
astrophysicist and geologists and
there's a plus there's a worry if we
don't have a magnetic
field that means the charged particles s
straight into us and don't get directed
to the poles would that be bad for life
on Earth so it might be you might think
it would be but there no particularly
striking Extinction episodes right uh at
the times when these Magi zero yeah
there's no there's no we've we by the
way animals are going extinct all the
time especially now because humans have
have their hands in this
process we're to it's the sixth
Extinction really all right uh so um so
yeah that that's in case you didn't know
that your compass points South that's
great all right this has been Star Talk
things you thought you knew NE to Grass
Tyson keep looking
[Music]
up